لكن المفاوضات التي تحدث عنها مكروسه
تنتظر حتما المعركه الشتاء او على الاقل
معركه مدينه بخموت التي تتركز عليها
الانظار الان هذه المدينه التي اصبحت نقطه
ربما تكون الاسخن في الحرب القتال للسيطره
على بخمود قد يشهد اكثر المعارك شراسه حتى
الان في اوكرانيا في اختبار لما يمكن ان
تكون عليه حرب الشتاء المرتقبه صور الخطوط
الاماميه المنشوره من بخموط اظهرت ان
المدينه التي كانت تضم سبعين الف سنه قد
اضحت انقادا وتحت وابل مستمر من نيران
المدفعيته روسيه
[موسيقى]
لكن ما هي هذه المدينه وما اهميه لماذا
القتال المحتدم عليها
على طريق رئيسي يؤدي الى مدينه سلوفي
الصناعيه التي لم تسيطر عليها روسيا
بالكامل بعد هي ايضا
لامدادات الجيش الاوكراني في المنطقه
وشهدت معارك عنيفه في عام 2014
و2015 عندما استولت القوات الانفصاليه
المواليه لروسيا لفتره وجيزه بالنسبه
لروسيا الاستيلاء على بخمود سيؤدي لقطع
خطوط الامداد الاوكرانيه اضافه لفتح
الطريق للقوات الروسيه للتقدم نحو
كروماتوسوفيانوس المعتقلين الرئيسيين
لاوكرانيا في مقاطعه
اكثر من خمسه اشهر قصفت القوات الروسيه
بخموت كما تسارعت وتيره الهجوم البري
بقياده مجموعه فاجنر الامنيه التي تضم
جنود سابقين روسيا تحتاج الى نصر في بخموت
لانها تفقد السيطره على مساحات واسعه من
شمال شرق اقليم خاركه بسبب هجوم مضاد
اوكراني الشهر الماضي اضافه لسيطره القوات
الاوكرانيه على خيرسو بين كار وفر تتراوح
العمليات العسكريه حول بخموت المدينه التي
هجرها 90% من سكانها بسبب المعارك بسبب او
بحسب حاكم الاقليم
[موسيقى]
اذا القوات الروسيه حول محمود بدات بتحقيق
بعض المكاسب في الاسابيع الاخيره بعد اشهر
من الهجمات المستمره على خط المواجهه
الاوكراني مع تواصل ارسال التعزيزات في
محاوله للسيطره على المدينه لكن وسط غياب
انباء دقيقه عن سير المعارك يتاهل بعد
المراقبين بان الروسي يبالغون في الحديث
عن تقدمهم بسبب الرغبه في استعاده بعض
الهدوء داخليا وسط تقارير عن تلاش الروح
المعنويه بين جنود الخطوط الاماميه ومع
اقتراب فصل الشتاء نشر الجيش الاوكراني
لقطات اظهرت جنود في خنادقهم التي يتحسنون
فيها كما نشاهد
ووصفه الظروف التي يعيشونها
وصفها المحللون بالبائسه مسؤول كبير في
الفنتاكون وصف الوضع حول بخموت بانه يبدو
مشابها جدا للاوضاع في الحرب العالميه
الاولى
[موسيقى]